a new Senate backed reports out this
week we learned about the most liked
Instagram post by Russian trolls it's a
photo of women's shoes posted by the
Russian account blacks to Graham and it
appears to have nothing to do with
politics but there's a lot more to this
post than meets the eye and the back
story gives us a glimpse of how Russian
operatives used sophisticated schemes to
take advantage of American businesses
and their social media following take a
closer look at the words accompanying
the post see this link to a different
Instagram account expression tease
that's important expression tease is a
real Pennsylvania business owned by this
man Steven Austin he sells all kinds of
t-shirts and products including ones
that promote the black lives matter
movement in the spring of 2017 a few
weeks before that Instagram post about
shoes went viral Austin got an
interesting message it said it was from
a group of social media managers focused
on helping the black community they were
offering a social media management
service for a monthly rate starting at
$300 a month
Austin began talking to the group which
called itself your digital face a
website for your digital face offers
more details about its so called service
it said the group managed 50 Instagram
accounts with a total of 2.5 million
followers and it featured examples of
the pages it promoted including Afro
Kingdom black business and American
veterans what Austin didn't know at the
time was that a bunch of accounts your
digital face said it ran were linked to
the st. Petersburg based internet
research agency the Russian troll farm
that was charged this year by special
counsel robert muller for interfering in
the u.s. election since he had no
marketing expertise and was busy running
his company austin said your digital
face was worth a shot
he started communicating with them over
Skype which said they were in California
and he soon sent them $300 a month and
his Instagram login credentials so they
could promote his page that PayPal
account was later revealed to be used by
the Russian trolls a few weeks after he
signed up that popular post about shoes
blew up with expression tees linked in
the text it got hundreds of thousands of
likes
in an email your digital face told
Austin it had given him a shout-out on
the page and it encouraged him to buy
more shout outs in order to boost his
followers austin said he didn't pay for
any additional shout outs but we talked
to other people who did austin said his
page was gaining enough traction with
the monthly service so he continued
paying your digital face until red flags
started cropping up months later in the
fall of 2017 austin said he started
getting notifications that the group was
trying to log into his account from
places all over the world including
ukraine frustrated with the problems it
was causing he eventually cut ties with
you our digital phase just months after
that email and paypal accounts connected
to your digital face became public in an
indictment of the russian tro farm and
this summer austin said he got a visit
from the FBI telling him he was a victim
the FBI declined to comment and Russia
has denied interfering in u.s. politics
so why did Russian operatives go after
Austin's business account and others
like it experts say it could have been
done for a variety of reasons it may
have helped Russian trolls map out
social networks and gather information
about Americans it could have also
helped them finance their interference
operations through service fees and make
their fake accounts appear more
legitimate Instagram said it reviewed
your digital faces activity and
determined that its services violated
the platform's Terms of Use while the
dot-com version of your digital face
went dark in recent months a similar
Russian URL is still active and despite
Austin having ended his relationship
with the group it still says that
Austin's business expression T's is a
client
you